Porque es importante este acuerdo que se
consigue
un placer Rosa estar con ustedes
nuevamente Bueno es un día histórico tú
lo has dicho lo dicho el secretario
general Porque después de quince años se
acuerda avanzar en la protección de la
biodiversidad del océano Esta es la
palabra clave protección de la alta mar
es aquella zona que está más allá de la
jurisdicción Más allá donde tienen
poderes los estados como son las
doscientas millas náuticas de ahí la
importancia y de ahí también lo que
costó llegar a este acuerdo que hoy día
formalmente es muy importante se adoptó
por consenso es decir por toda la
comunidad internacional y le pregunto
han sido 15 años no hasta que se
adoptara por consenso como usted nos lo
decía que ha sido lo más difícil de
acordar entre los países de Naciones
Unidas
bueno balancear los intereses en juego
ha sido la problemática más grande que
enfrentó este acuerdo y para ser
específico y concreto los temas
relacionados con recursos genéticos
marinos esto es muy importante porque
ahí está la base para el desarrollo de
medicinas que son muy relevantes Para
curar enfermedades y por lo tanto los
intereses en juego y en particular los
intereses de las farmacéuticas
multinacionales han estado presentes y
al final se ha logrado un acuerdo Para
repartir la explotación y el acceso
estos recursos tanto en aspectos
monetarios como no monetarios también
avanzar en reglas claras para establecer
una red mundial en la altamar de áreas
marinas protegidas tenemos esta triple
crisis climática que está afectando por
cierto al océano y por lo tanto hacer el
enlace con la convención de
biodiversidad y Los acuerdos para llegar
al 30% de protección del océano al 2030
es clave este acuerdo bbnj como se
denomina en su sigla en inglés para
avanzar en protección de áreas marinas
protegidas que deben quedar apartadas de
la explotación de la actividad humana
Por cierto y Cristian le preguntó qué
camino queda todavía por recorrer como
decía el secretario general de Naciones
Unidas y cómo se va a acabar
materializando si nos puede dar algún
ejemplo de cómo se va a proteger
finalmente qué van a hacer los estados
bueno los colegas hoy día en Naciones
Unidas comentaban que hoy es el final
del comienzo porque con la adopción
formal comienza ahora el trabajo de
implementación de este acuerdo dentro de
la dinámica de Naciones Unidas se
requiere que el acuerdo vuelva a la
asamblea general de donde viene el
mandato para la negociación y se trabaje
lo que se denomina una conferencia de
preparatoria donde se tienen que adoptar
las normas de procedimiento donde se
tienen que comenzar a establecer los
órganos subsidiarios para qué Para poner
el acuerdo en funcionamiento una vez y
esto muy importante que 60 países
ratifiquen este acuerdo y quiero hacer
una una mención especial a los países
latinoamericanos que han trabajado
conjuntamente durante toda la
negociación para tener una sola voz y
eso ha sido muy importante entre ellos
chile que ha ofrecido ser sede de la
secretaría de este acuerdo pero no
quiero eh dejar de lado El ejemplo
concreto Si en el futuro por ejemplo Más
allá de las doscientas millas se quiere
poner una planta que busca extraer gas
pues bien el estado que desarrolle esa
iniciativa tendrá que someter a impacto
ambiental y tendrá que cooperar con este
acuerdo para poder establecer la
salvaguardia ambientales y evitar que
Estas actividades se desarrollen Si no
cuentan con los más altos estándares que
el propio acuerdo establece para estas
materias de explotación de futuras
actividades en la altamar